- [Voiceover] So I have
an expression here.
Three times the entire
expression 5x plus six,
and then plus the expression 7x plus two
and all of that times four.
And what I encourage you
to do is pause this video
and see if you can
simplify this expression.
And I'll give you a hint.
You're gonna have to do some distribution
and then some combining of like terms.
All right, now I'm assuming
you've had a go at it.
Now let's work through this together.
So as I mentioned, when
I see this three times
the entire expression 5x plus six,
I want to distribute that three.
So I want to multiply that three times 5x
and that three times the six.
So three times 5x, well if I have five Xs
and I have three times
that, I'm gonna have 15 Xs.
And then three times six is 18.
So this part of the expression
we have now simplified
to 15x plus 18.
Now let's do the next part.
So here I have this larger
expression written before
this four but I wanna do the same thing.
I just wanna distribute the four.
It doesn't matter whether I'm multiplying,
if I have the three or if I
have the number on the left side
or the right side, so
let's distribute this four.
I wanna do four times 7x and
I wanna do four times two.
Four times 7x, well
that's going to be 28x,
28x.
And then four times two
is going to be eight.
So we're almost there.
This part of our expression has
simplified to 28x plus eight
and now we can combine similar terms.
So we have 15 Xs,
and then we can add that to 28 Xs.
Let me do this in a different color.
If I have 15 of something
and I add 28 of something
of that same something to it,
well then I'm gonna have what, 43 Xs.
So 43 Xs.
15x plus 28 Xs, I added
the coefficients there,
that's gonna be 43 Xs.
And then 18 plus eight.
Hey, let me do this in a new color.
So 18 plus eight is going to be 26.
And we're done.
We've simplified this longer expression.
We did some distribution then we combined
some terms to get 43x plus 26.